-I command you!
-Why should we listen to you?
[ Crowd shouting ]
-Because I...am...God!
[ All gasping, shouting ]
♪♪
-So, you play God.
-Yes.
There was -- there was a thing
on that robe, on that cape,
though, that was not safe
for television, I don't think.
-Oh, really?
-But, great!
-Go back,
rewind and pause, kids.
[ Laughter ]
I think we would've
got away with it, Bowen.
-Damn!
-Oh.
-Sorry, Standards and Practices.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guess what.
It was hard finding a clip
from "Dicks: The Musical."
-I know, I'm sure.
-We didn't want
to have you on here
and show a 2 1/2-second clip.
-Sure. You couldn't
have called it...
I can't -- I can't even come up
with an alternative
to "Dicks: The Musical"
that is safe for television.
-This was a UCB show
that you were involved with
back in 2014?
-I was not involved.
I was just, like, a lowly,
lowly audience member.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was, but I saw it like
multiple times.
And it was -- this was,
like, back in 2014, 2015.
And it was Josh Sharp
and Aaron Jackson
who are in the movie
who play these twin brothers.
It's a gay "Parent Trap,"
basically, that's a musical.
And, but then they did
this show like once a month
and then it became
this, like, meeting ground
and this touchpoint for a lot
of queer comedians in the city,
like, who had never
really talked
to each other before that,
who didn't hang out,
and it was -- it was great.
We all, like, went out to...
They said,
"We're doing a talk-back
at a bar around the corner."
And it was just an excuse
for us to, like,
just talk and hang out.
-That's so nice.
So, I'm assuming
when they reached out
and said, "Bowen,
we'd like you to play God,"
It was a quick yes.
-Quick yes.
And I'm really honored.
It's like, what, me,
Morgan Freeman,
Alanis Morissette,
and George Burns?
Like, that's a crazy...
-Yeah, those are the four gods.
-Those are the -- That's
the Mount Rushmore of gods.
We're like the "Sex and
the City" girls of Gods.
-How -- I mean, I know
you always do a lot of research
about a character
before you play it.
What did you find
that drew you to God?
-Well, I read the entire Bible
cover to cover,
and in Aramaic.
[ Laughter ]
No, I...I...
So, God in this movie is this,
like, really petulant
sort of gay entity.
And it got me thinking,
like, my way in was like,
God is kind of a messy queen,
you know?
Like, he's so dramatic,
floods the world,
makes it rain frogs.
That's campy.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you know,
the whole Book of Job is him,
like, playing The Sims
on this one guy, like...
You know?
So, I feel like that is --
this is a very, like,
it's a "new" portrayal of God,
but it's like, it's God
the way we understand God.
-Yes, that we haven't
been able to admit
that's what God
has been telling us.
-Exactly.
-And now you're finally like,
let's just own it.
-And let's just own it.
Everyone's free to just call God
a messy queen from now on.
[ Laughter ]
This is a great cast.
Nathan Lane.
-Yes.
-Megan Mullally is in it.
-Uh-huh.
-But really all anybody
who's seen the movie
is talking about is,
is the sewer boys.
-The sewer boys.
-So, the sewer boys
are these two characters
that belong to Nathan Lane
in the film.
-Yep. That's right.
-They're, like,
just prosthetic dudes.
-Yes, they're real puppets.
They're prosthetic dudes.
-Here's a good sense of
their actual size.
-That's right.
So, that's them with us
on the red carpet.
I...
Someone made me hold one of them
on the red carpet,
and I wasn't --
I thought they were
really adorable, really cute.
But then when I touched them,
they're...
Whoever made them,
made them out of, like, real
skin and bone, it seemed like.
I was like, this is vile.
But I'm curious --
You've lived in New York
a long time.
Do you believe that
there is, like, a species,
a lateral species
of, like, sewer people?
Like, mole people?
What do you think?
-100%.
-Yes!
-Yeah. 100%.
-There has to be.
-And I think they're not
that upset about it.
-No.
-Yeah.
-Great real estate down there.
-Yeah. I think they're great.
Like, absolutely.
They have so much space
and they're, like...
-It's by the train.
Talking about God,
you actually, as a kid,
wanted to make a deal
with the devil.
-Yes, I think...
I guess I admitted this
on a press thing for this movie.
Someone unlocked
a memory for me.
They said, "Did you ever sell...
Have you ever sold your soul
to the devil?"
I said, "Wait a minute,
I did!"
[ Laughter ]
When I was like 11 years old,
there was an episode of
"The Simpsons" that was on.
It's called
"Bart Sells His Soul."
Season seven, episode four,
and written by Greg Daniels,
who we all know and love
from "The Office."
And Bart basically sells
his soul to Milhouse,
and then I think by the end
of the episode, he, like,
you know, asks Satan
to give it back.
And I was -- I watched that
in my basement,
being like, "You can do that?
Great!"
[ Laughter ]
-So, you did not watch the
episode as a cautionary tale.
-No, no. Purely encouraged.
And just had, like,
an imaginary conversation
with Satan.
I think I just wanted
to play, like, a video game.
I think I just wanted to play,
like, ironically,
like Diablo 2 or something.
And I got it, and I...
And so he upheld his bargain,
and I think
I'm still technically
locked into this deal.
-You seem fine, though.
-I don't know, I feel like
I come off soulless sometimes.
Right, guys?
But I blame Greg Daniels
for this Faustian
bargain, though.
-Yeah, well, you've got to
pin it on somebody.
You might as well pin it on him.
-He owes me a show.
-Yeah, there you go.
Did you...Do you have any...
You know, I know, five months
of not doing "SNL."
Are there any sketches
you've come up with
over the years
that you have pitched
that you wish
had been received better?
-Oh, yeah. I mean,
just always, always, always.
But the one that I think really,
really, like, got away from me
was Jenna Ortega was here last
season, and at Monday pitch,
I pitched her this thing where
she is a children's book author
and she writes a book
that's kind of like
"Can You Give a Mouse a Cookie."
-"Can You Give a Mouse a Cookie"
is a great book.
-Great book.
-And it's about how things just
get, like, sort of...
You give a mouse a cookie
and that's just the beginning
of the problem, yeah.
-Just the beginning
of a problem.
And I pitched her
a children's book title
that she could be
the author of, called
"Can You Give a Bitch a Break?"
[ Laughter ]
And, didn't take.
Didn't take.
-How could that not take?
-I know! I don't know.
-They've lost their minds
up there!
-Exactly.
-Hey, thanks for being back.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
-I'm so happy "SNL" is back.
I'm so happy you're back
in the building.
Bowen Yang!
"SNL" premieres Saturday
on NBC and Peacock.
"Dicks: The Musical"
is in select theaters now
and nationwide October 20th.
We'll be right back
with Jason Blum.